hello everybody my name is Mark blarin
what wall oh really
don't okay it was you so much for
joining I don't know thank you so much
for joining us Adam on my graph we got
fill from fire UK here oh yeah he's
still here
you saw him in the last episode but he's
here still I'm still here away still
alive okay alright so yeah wait is still
not use ha ha ha ha ha ha that's butters
my butters been a while did you visit it
Oh Bobby I don't know what you're
talking about butters are anyway yeah so
wait is not here again he's leo drive
myself probably having hot sex we would
go for that
Wow well I mean they haven't seen each
other in what how long how long like 3-4
months uh that signs about alright I'm
fine Phil you don't know it's exactly oh
I'm actually drunk oh yeah so sorry I
don't think let it happen ok anyway so
we are gonna build oh ma Oh Maj - way -
Omar so I need a lot of pink wool sorry
Oh Frank wall oh my god I got tools Tom
oh yay ha ha ha ha hey I have a lot of
pink wool you guys are pink well uh no I
got the admin starter kit ya bunch of
stuff yay all right so we got a pink
wool so we're gonna build my exact
mental image of Wade Oh God
well now I don't think it's gonna end
well yeah yeah there we go done you like
you guys you like it you like I don't
see where you are like this you see it
oh I'm a chose it's a penis ha ha ha I
thought we were past that mark no why
don't we ever bet you're gonna if you're
gonna do a penis at least do it to the
scale of fire UK okay just no big deal
of weight oh sorry yeah scale of weight
there we go that's at least 5 by 5 ha ha
ha
oh this is a collective fire UK penis
here yeah I don't even know why I'm
allowed on YouTube if I keep doing
things like this is this allowed
apparently we've done it before
yeah this is not even remotely the
person I want anything like my doors are
gonna be like what the hell you doing
you can time-lapse a giant penis well if
we we can't do it on our channel so you
might we'll do it on yours right well
yeah yeah yeah well you could do it on
your channel I don't see why Jenna oh
we're comes along or they have tried
during a time lapse they've tried to put
a penis you put a stop to that or did
you let him let him do it I'd let him do
it
good good good okay all right so now we
start on did you want to do the other
testicle
hi I got one ball if I get to the other
one I'll get that so I wonder if zombies
obviously have like the penis cannon
loaded up with that was pretty funny I
don't know why but your laugh seems so
insincere right there papa
ma my awesome Nordic world yeah my last
seemed insincere yeah it did that was so
funny when we did that yeah that was but
your laugh was he's like ah ha ha ha
well I was remembering a giant penis
whoa what is going on over here what is
what is this this does not look right
what what were you doing I didn't do
this who is this
I'm not even over there I can see you
guys with Al in the distance but I'm
building my own amage - wait wait whoa
whoa whoa I've been riding testicles to
the testicle oh oh that first thing
that's that's all waiting of way to get
a penis with penis testicles that have
testicles this is an important lesson
guys guys out there check regularly
check regularly sack regularly if your
testicles are penises I don't know what
the hell you did
tickle is not a penis it's just a
tactical on attack if you have your
testicles have testicles you need to see
a doctor
uh-huh yes please it's very important yo
dawg i heard you like testicles test
testicle so i what testicles on your
testicles so you can what life while you
what what hi Phil we have a certain
level of quality day videos I mean the
standard no no thought of improving
things
maybe I should like build the penis of
the height let me again
I don't know but you get that high oh we
could wait we do wait wait this long to
wait isn't it yeah it's to wait not cuz
I need to make this smaller I regret my
da ha ha ha ha ha okay so uh wait zombie
TNT hey you're learning that's exactly
how these drunk minecraft go I can't be
bothered to demolish this so I need TNT
in it okay yeah Bob where are you oh
you're over here wait for this one I'm
gonna need more than one what is this I
don't know I'm feeling it's awfully thin
don't you think I'm coach as well
what Oh Go Go Go my favorite sport team
go wait wait hang on there's no waiting
in women drunk minecraft wait no it's
you blow it up right now
or someone blows it up for you but but
but how am I supposed to wait what Oh
boom Oh much better
okay so other than these penis oh ma
jeez - where's your house I'm not
building a penis we're gonna make a
house out look like suspiciously like a
penis I'm building a castle in the sky
duh Oh out of wool yeah so okay where's
your not a good castle in the sky hmm
I'm not a good Minecraft illa billah'
nuts no girls allowed we'll fill will
getting Emma haha so I'm giving your
will will fill yeah
well well well if I'm a lumen channel
Pig castle in the sky no no it's about
far UK obviously yeah run oh my council
sky right here like much higher than
yours it's gonna grandeur everybody five
what wait wait for the bridge bridge
fixed okay oh okay Bob good good job
there mark your jerk
what Brooklyn I do this is my castle in
the sky and finds green you guys don't
walk around nestled in the sky first
time I take another shot and through you
guys are you gonna built your own castle
with blackjack and hookers zombie build
your castle with blackjack while I drink
honey Jack by the way I'm making honey
get the castle and I've taken I've taken
five shots already know that makes you
sleepy yeah actually big probably wrong
response bro I got it I got a sober up
before tonight because I gotta go see
something bout a wallaby something
that's a British thing right for someone
about a wallaby
ah yeah yeah I think so yeah I figured
I've using like the UK with Australia no
well same thing
baseball's worship the swing it's so
good ways no it's exactly it's like you
know exactly the same I'm pretty sure I
like I Bob back me up on this
no come on Bob back me up I'll go oh all
right hang on I'm just gonna be more
insulting than fine screw you guys let's
see how could I be even more insulting
see your Scottish Rite don't we not
there Oh ericom's we go right for it oh
oh oh
Hughie Blarney Bucky no key foggy ah
little tiny lady like it's Irish Oh
y'all turn y'all live well
hey we're never claimed that he was
intelligent all right just so we're
clear on this it's clearly
wait a minute I learned my my Scottish
accent from Colin Mochrie and Robin
Williams no the Demoman from GF to Robin
Williams hey that's a good one right
he'd keep Scottish didn't he or
something he's not is he he's no no you
know I'm not taking a shot as soon as I
get done with this shock tart O'Reilly
drinking game let's play whoa what the
Marco famously Scottish people as you
can and oh hey Phil look up look up
watch daga zombie I want to fly I need
to see that Robbie
mm-hmm there we go ha ha ha oh god no
idea I had no idea why are you building
your castle in the sky directly above
mine ha ha ha
Mark Harris was just gonna drop down on
me I didn't do that and you made him do
that no I didn't did I tell you that
Phil yes in my bad Scottish accent make
you do that yeah I found the water Hey
ah ha ha by the water I can't fly out ah
we die huh
ok there we go ok I'm out alright so
yeah um what was I doing
oh yeah more accent I can do a Swedish
accent well here the Swedish hi I'm yes
/ ah yes fer yes hi I'm Yates feels like
a Swedish name ah joke it's supposed to
be Jasper but because it's Swedish it
must be a spur oh oh I see what you did
there a field it's a Canadian oh no it's
whatever their nationality is in Skyrim
that's what it is
oh yeah skyrim let's play and he did
like 98 episodes and all you ever did
was say was the characters in the game
said hey shut up it was entertaining
maybe fried yes still I still haven't
finished Skyrim people ask me what's a
Wally
uh hey what the hell where my flying go
grandpa boat [ __ ] Oh Oh goddamn it
ha ha broke my bowling with your face
silly Scottish person silly Scott I
think is what it's called I think that's
what it is I'm up in the sky you know I
wore a kilt
to minecon and everything you did yeah
for because someone dared me to because
I said that was Scottish and they said
no you're not I was like yeah I mean
like oh if your squash well you just
wear a kilt at Minecon I was like I will
do that and I don't know oh well good
for you screw that guy cool story bro is
you ready to him I know but well I I
made sure that she no crap it wasn't
even on the live stream that like when I
was at the panel like before we started
I just would like show tape one I was
like challenge completed [ __ ] look
good for you I'm gonna take my shot now
it's been sitting here so how many sure
are you taking there's my six one it's
like I'm you were gonna bring the pain I
don't see you drinking a bunch you don't
see me at all
I don't see me either I don't have a
feel the need to the clearer every time
I do it like oh hey guys hey guys I'm
doing a shot now well okay yeah he's
some like full shots always been play
yeah you say that's me that's me that's
half my beer gone so oh okay alright
whatever
by the way that whole Jager and monster
thing I finished out like within 10
minutes so I'm on like my fourth beer oh
well whoop-dee-do okay prove anything
oh I bet you I bet you didn't even go to
minecon I wouldn't you don't even have a
channel oh oh well I go to Cape so mmm I
could have a cape I don't have any of
these things
yeah that's cuz Bob you don't know what
are you guys doing in my wait castle get
out of here this is your wave castle
what so wait what makes any chance
ornament on the front door what makes is
so Wayde like I don't see anything
special here Oh who's going off to the
front Oh Bert maybe you push me off for
no reason hey I didn't hit you I did not
get to verse like I did wait wait wait
wait what uh well you guys defacing my
castle you have a stick you suck so much
yes I do have a sick surprise
okay right what's what's the contestant
ready at America doctored our donut hard
harder well obviously the guy who plays
minecraft for a living
would be better in Minecraft at me I you
do you do basically right yeah kind of
kinda oh ah oh it's a draw draw huh look
at that
where's the troll you didn't be very
stir anything yeah well I just suck at
it okay so our homage is to wait are
done
may his it's not done may his soul rest
in pieces or something I don't know
he's not dead by the way I want to
reiterate wait is not bad no matter what
he was dead because I keep hinting at it
for some strange reason haha like we'll
wait take this time to remember ah
associate who is no longer with us who
we never liked in the beginning hence
why I said associate not friend yeah
okay yeah all right I haven't even met
the guy yet I'm Mikey yeah I feel bad we
were kind of ripping on him I mean
you're giving a bad initials we should
we should be you know everyone knows
wait
everyone knows Wade hey zombie you got
any more cool things like that low low
low low low low low sign chair legs
hassle stun I fear I feel like weight is
like a hidden bro me and brownie or ever
oh he probably I wouldn't doubt it haha
Castle wait no that's not a penis
haha mmm-hmm wait wait there's a chest
go here and guess what's going inside it
what penises remark I get in I got him
wait oh damn it you rearranged it why
would you think that penis
I'm not penis there we go it was a penis
until he rearranged it actually that
just looks like the flux capacitor hang
on it looks like a flux capacitor no I'm
dead serious look you look it does it
was the flux capacitor
we're gonna go back Marty we gotta go
back that's worse - I was gonna say
oh my god uncle what do you do okay so
this castle will remain here for a time
being and we need to carry on to our
next amazing build that we do venture
you know I've always wondered how do you
organize people to actually build cool
coordinated black here's this hidden
secret we're not really that organized
space expand we have a lot of luck yeah
but I mean it's so weird because I would
do like a 12 hour livestream with
Minecraft and I have people I'm playing
with it I tell like okay
build this and then they all get better
we we stockpile like reference images we
build like templates beforehand so
people know what they're doing okay ooh
roughly into his eyes right yeah yeah
that eight dirt block it ate it what I
hate it haha killing mommy and
everything I'm the best dancer ever was
oh no I don't think so I don't know no
he was he was holding the dirt block and
then he placed it alright is my mouth
yeah no he placed it knows in his mouth
I'm sorry you were in his mouth uh-uh oh
oh oh oh get out of my castle for some
reason I thought of the goofy movie I
only see that that's you know I'd you're
the goofy movie oh yeah I love the
Google survive hell going on hi
why you being such a dick Wade fade yeah
you pushed me off I didn't do anything
you put me off I saw it as my buddies
over players anymore oh you would know
that you actually played Minecraft Oh
condescending comment about Minecraft oh
yeah well where's your other half Phil
where's your other half he is no longer
with us he's dead just like Wade yeah
what has been waits with all the random
death recently it was so sad
wait I know what would make this bridge
a more amazing bridge to diesels
well I'm just gonna cut a cost is this
is gonna be a penis episode just
everywhere you look what are you doing
to the he's putting on it he's putting
studs in it you know oh the sky Oh God
give me fly give me find that thing is
enormous give enough why I want to see a
time-lapse of that holy jeez holy crap
oh Jesus ha we know because the coolest
thing I've ever seen I have five you
know you know the origin of this troll
face isn't actually from anything
trolling it's the cool guy face you know
robot right Bob back me up on this it's
not actually the troll face is he
written origin it's that one comment
that was made in ms paint where the guy
is pulled over the cops and he's like
alright it's okay I'll just use my cool
face and the face he gives to the cops
yeah it becomes like get the [ __ ] out of
here remember yeah no one no one
remembers that but this is actually not
the origin anyway whatever this more
students yeah it is it is a very good
troll face bro
I'll wall you mad bro Jesus thing is
gigantic that's what you wanted only one
two eights oh wait it's already there
huh what's with this green wall why is
your green one this thing well Marlene
wall can we see you it's called shading
and lighting and and art and and and and
that I don't know Bob say something
Bob Tatum I don't know why that's green
wool hi I don't play this game very well
I don't know I don't know what
impression to you all have of me but I
don't know anything about this game yeah
I believe that Bob where you people say
to me like you were saying earlier like
you're the expert of my craft what we do
in Minecraft is not minecraft let's like
creates if we don't survive or bad
opposed that's true who would you say is
the best minecraft er
well I would mean Matt no in the world
oh uh it want me to say him there are
multiple categories categories yeah like
you know best builder best you know
commentator well I'd - no I mean like
God did I mean I could use your words
I don't know speak with your mouth hole
alright whatever you're no help at all
all right we're gonna get the best at
redstone I guess I don't know he's hello
settling sapling i sethbling sethbling
he's a guy that I always hear about
doing on the redstone stuff so then use
a minecon on everything so I'm gonna say
him like the calculators yeah but you
made like an entire tf2 map I would
redstone and no Mulligan rep so like it
is actually playable so holy crap you
can do if you can do that with redstone
and it's just with white stone Oh God
my killer I got white stone oh yeah I
know I know you're not used to
commentating for this long I mean it was
bridge lost stress on you right right or
no ideas no right no I talked for 12
hours at a time it's I've I'm very used
to it are you sighs talking and rambling
about [ __ ] right we've wasted 21 minutes
doing absolutely dick diddly so we'll do
it faster I'm the host what we I don't
do anything as a host I just you know
you guys you guys do your thing and I
condescendingly judge you
oh well I did not know this yes this is
how drunk minecraft works I act like I'm
super important and then I make fun of
bobbing wait you know what Bob we should
we should go and strike right here
uh-huh
ah sneezy laughs I don't get a joke I
don't get the joke Oh No
hey I can fly this a joke while the a
and equal signs and the what is that the
clothes l-bracket that's no joke it's a
penis yeah
yeah I'm with wish apply slow motions
bleeping you have to crouch
hey we simply use your bare hands and
play with wool okay mom I'm eating a
shock charge by the way I don't sell
them much anymore but I love them now
yes
hey doing you know about MA your dick I
was trying to hit the wool underneath
you I guess this is what we can expect
from the British oh then we're gonna
learn it mm-hmm okay you know filler
where I just explained that no one in
our country actually gives a [ __ ] the
throw burger edition we're like and we
don't care yeah I mean you're like it's
true I guess yeah I am our country is
like the biggest country for not giving
a [ __ ] ever ever really I don't know
ever you yeah what about Canada they
don't give a [ __ ]
no but they're nice badgers there's like
difference between like completely being
cynical and not giving a [ __ ] and then
just like being nice and not caring hmm
okay I could do that
all right so like if I like you know
bumped into or something like the
Canadian would go oh I'm really sorry
I'm really sorry even though he did
nothing whereas I would go oh what the
[ __ ] he doing
yeah oh I'm really sorry sorry about
that
boots ah sorry ah sorry I got a such a
hard noggin there I did I hurt your fist
when you punched me oh gosh I'm so sorry
I actually have a Canadian friend that's
best friend I went to candidate for luck
friend oh I I told not that but hey what
the hell what why why Bob I didn't do
anything to you how come everyone can
fly but me no you have a cape with you
my world
what the hell we made this looks like a
face Dragon Ball Z battle mark or the
end of the matrix don'tdon't Dada Dada
Dada Dada sure
Oh Star Wars oh he's like the most
incorrect references ever minecraft
we're gonna make this battle fighting
with wooden tools Dragon Ball Z and hell
were singing the theme to Star Wars
dying of food this hang up where are you
all rain apples on you I got two apples
he's on me ah I dropped an apple care
package incoming wait I better not have
it land on me all that's gone it's a one
in the way do you guys play like what
what games do you play to relax and have
fun um well I used to be a big World of
Warcraft guy but not so much anymore
yeah oh yeah I raided hardcore really
Bob knows I was his roommate he was
pretty ridiculous yeah I played since
vanilla so um we have at one of our
moderators he plays ah there's nothing
wrong with the game itself I don't judge
people but it just if you if the only
way that I can play is to play hardcore
rating and that sucks up so much um I
just don't have the time anymore did I
just see Wade where he I thought I was
teaching something I saw a character
standing there and it wasn't you and
Phil and I Howard well ii-i've I don't
know I played well but I never really
got heavy into it because I'm the kind
of guy when I play no more I like
playing with a group and I like doing
like the question doing story stuff and
the guy that was helping me through it
just decided to like speed through
everything I see and it just made it
yeah I mean for the game to be good you
have to experience it and you do need a
good crew to play with like my gosh I
played with were some of the best
players in the world the holy pally
probably was I wouldn't be surprised if
he was the best player in the world but
you know yeah like I just got way too
into it and took up my life and I forgot
about that right now I don't really have
a game that I played to relax our our
games and to I will end you in my pink
will äj-- I was hitting me with a nap
you
with your pink village yeah yeah that's
the thing
I will pink you today oh yeah pink me
all over the place
I will say that your indie horror one
play ones like one-off things are
amazing to watch on my lunch break I've
actually had I've had a customer ask me
what the hell was going on because we
were in the stockroom just laughing at
it and I really Oh what were you guys
watching I was like I was just some guy
[ __ ] his pants and nothing it's cool
thank you for describing me so well I
know dick that's pretty accurate
mark I know you're mad about it's not
wrong I mean it's not wrong you're just
an absolute light after it's just don't
drown now gonna wait for all to be over
uh-huh oh um oh by the way I was always
good now that you're you know you're
doing more like let's play stuff how do
your fans set you know watch the time
lapses respond to that sort of stuff
we've had a lot of hates from stuff and
also love people I mean basically when
people whenever we put a video that
isn't a time-lapse out there's a comment
saying where the time-lapse is like
every time like it not just comes a
territory an every time it's not
Minecraft you'll always get the people
saying this is a Minecraft what are you
doing like yeah like you'll can only do
one thing yeah yeah like we're a
minecraft channel we can only do
minecraft we're not we're a multi gaming
channel just we'd love doing minecraft
so that's what we've kind of stuck with
uh yeah um but I don't know I mean most
of our stuff goes down pretty well when
we do it I mean we did like our basic
goal as if if a video gets on average
above like 10k or so with our voyage
it's good you know there's enough people
there that like it it'll be good I mean
and in the retrospect to the fact we
have 175 K subscribers you know they
have a low benchmark for something to be
successful but yeah it's surprising
because I get 10k on my videos now and I
mean it's not bad I mean what the people
who have subscribed to your channel
obviously go for this yeah the time
lapses I mean even though we have
minecraft has become an indie horror
game for you know our zombie can you
give me some gas tanks please guess what
go cast eggs no no no no no army no gas
but we do need to end the episode on a
boom cuz we got a minute and poof solder
we go how long left blob that blow up
that trollface blow it up oh oh my god
god no god mode god mode on each other
oh god no hide in the troll face oh god
I need to survive come at me bro damn
gas everywhere oh Jesus
there's guys we never do anything
constructive on these games here go
stand next to the truck I saw a gas
shoot shoot towards the trophies ah give
me back one dammit
are you dead you die I spawned like
water expecting the watch he can't fly
mark remember oh yeah yeah cuz I don't
have fly because I didn't update things
bow I'm curly safe in my wool cat ass
alone Jesus there finally home on fire
yes
so if they shooted this it'll catch on
fire zombie can I have some flint and
steel I want to light this whole thing
on fire it's all run on fire yeah
they've already lost weight God come at
me bro
I'm coming in yeah okay I got Flint
still it's like this suck off yep yep I
think wool burns doesn't will burn yeah
it appears to burn my castle the sky is
going down in flames
alright look very good alright that'll
do it for this mo god no tnt pimples all
over the trophy
uh I've no lighter about item I'm gonna
do it I'm trying I can't go to a value
it I'm doing it do you do it shut up
they were quicker do it quicker knowing
it golly there's no ideas happening oh
yeah that's oh god is lighting a bald up
whoa oh oh oh oh is you guys ha ha ha I
am on the ground by some cactus that's
awesome ok that is all the time that is
all the time we have for this episode so
thank you all so much for watching hope
you enjoyed it and as always we will see
you in the next video Oh God
bye bye bye
huh I thought you laughs were you what
the hell ah die ah - whoo you do all my
help